all right marshall
marshall where'd you grow up where are
you from originally ah from michigan
the park
pontiac
that's in oakland county
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad i had a mom
and uh my dad my mother got a divorce
when i was still young yet
and then my mother remarried okay
and uh
we got along pretty good but he was an
alcoholic and he ended up dying
and uh my mother more or less it was i
had
three
three sisters
and a brother younger brother
i'm the oldest boy
my mother ended up working two jobs
trying to raise us all
and uh
we got along pretty good
but uh
i ended up getting into juvenile because
i got into trouble and stuff and
my mother went ahead and went to the
court and the court released me to go in
the military
and they dropped all charges
and uh i went in the military
i did well on my job but i just couldn't
adjust to
service so i ended up getting i got out
in 1958
so
i had reserved but i didn't have to go
to reserve because of
it was other than animal conditions
and uh
basically that's
i guess that's about all you would need
there in my background yeah from home
but uh what kind of work have you done
in your life
oh i did a lot of work uh i worked in
the factories up in michigan
and until i moved down here in 69
and i worked at channel 10 out here on
gandy
i run studio camera
and the station sold out
and they brought their own people into
coming and bought it
so i left channel 10 then at that point
i went to work for a morrow corporation
and they built solid waste sewer plants
and i worked there until 86 until i got
sent to prison
and you uh you were married
yes i was i got married
i married my wife
she started visiting me while i was in
prison when i got released we got we got
married
and uh
i had two daughters so you you did
prison time before you got married
yes what was that for the prison time uh
i wrote bad checks
oh i see and then you got married i got
married had two kids
i had two daughters
and then you got in trouble again
yes tell me about that
well the i
i molested my daughter
and a neighbor daughter
and the neighbor daughter was nine years
old
my daughter started when she was about
about six
and it continued a lot of it was
fondling up until she got up to around
14.
it escalated to me having a uh
have an
intercourse with her
one time and then and then it came to
light to the police department of what
was going on
and i was arrested
and then
i was appointed a lawyer
and the lawyer
tried to get me a plea negotiation
well the judges the judge was going to
give me a plea negotiation
and she told me it would just be a
formality of going in front of him
and take my plea from not
from guilty than not guilty
and then that would make a plea
negotiation
so when i got in front of the judge
he was under the intention
the understanding
with my lawyer i guess
that i would receive 15 years
for attempted sexual battery
well when i got in front of him
and he started reading off the time he
was giving me
the prosecutor says excuse me your honor
mr white is pleading guilty to attempted
capital sexual battery
and he says i just give the man 15 years
she says well she says
it's capital
attempted capital sexual battery
so he rescinded that sentence he just
gave me
and gave me 50 years in prison
and 30 years probation
well at that time they took up took time
off of that 50 years
plus good behavior in prison
and that brought the time down a little
bit
a third off
the probation i had two counts other
words
one on the neighbor daughter
and my daughter
from period of life six to fourteen
and uh
my wife uh
we got a divorce while i went back i
went to prison 86.
we got a divorce in 88
because she met somebody and she didn't
want to be dating someone else
still being married to me
so she got a divorce in 88.
she asked me if it was all all right
with me to pile the paperwork
for the divorce and i said yeah okay
so i did
trying to savor some money there
and we got divorced in in 88
the 30-year probation
is still running right now
and uh
i was going to ask for early term on my
probation because of my age and my
health is not getting
any better
i've had a stint put in my heart
i've had other things done surgically
how old are you now
how old are you now 83 83 and you've
been out for how long
uh
like i said i got released from arcadia
treatment center
in 2011
[Music]
so i've been out i lived here for a
while then i moved to where i'm living
now
so
i've been out since 2011.
and looking back at your life do you i
mean you seem to be you're you're
attracted to young girls right
yes
and that is something that just you how
do you how do you view it it's just
something that you have in your
in your dna you just
uh it wasn't because of something that
happened to you as a kid or anything
like that
i'm not sure when it's when it started i
think something happened to me
and i just
oh you think you think maybe you were
touched when you were young i believe so
i i'm
that's a little fuzzy with me i'm not
sure exactly when
but something
got me
curious
and interested in that
and uh
like i say my mother
seen it i was not not doing good so she
she had to judge
when i went in front of the judge in
michigan
she recommended i would go in the
military if the judge would drop the
charges there
and uh the judge agreed to it
and let me go in the military
and so therefore
i settled that end in michigan
when i when i got out of the military in
58 i went to bed i went to work in the
factory up there
and in 69 like i say i moved to florida
and i ended up working at tv station
um
a moral corporation like i mentioned
earlier yeah now you're in a sex
offender mobile home park excuse me
you're in you're in a mobile home park
for sex offenders now i was living here
but i'm not now i'm living over in a
house right behind a comfort land oh
you're right next door i'm 54 yeah
i sure i sure the house is another
another gentleman
and uh of course the rent is getting so
high they built a bunch of new homes
down a promise and
that appraisal
raised the rent of everybody else in
that area
tell me about your relationship with
your
with your daughter after this happened
well it was confusing for her
and it caused her a lot of grief a lot
of anxieties
not
confusion on her love for me as our
father
and she still
she got both my daughters are married my
wife ended up making sure they graduated
high school
and they married good men
and
i don't hear from them now because it
was part of my stipulation
that i would not associate with minors
and i would not contact my daughters
they could contact me if they wanted to
but i was not to contact them
so i haven't talked to them since i was
released in prison
or from arcadia
what are your
feelings
about
what you did to the neighbor's girl the
neighbor's girl and your daughter after
going through treatment at arcadia and
two years of treatment here
i realized how terrible a person i was
and i feel
i feel really sorry about what i did
i can't change that
but i've tried to be a good person since
i've been released
from prison
like i say
when i lived here
we've got a lot of older people lives
here i would come down and help them
with their yard work and stuff and
painting trailers and stuff
and
i tried to give back some of what i took
no
and
i've tried to be a better person i think
i've done a pretty good job
i've not had any violations of my
probation
i've not had any trouble with law
enforcement
i watch a lot of tv and
i work on my yard where i live
did you did you continue to have
the desire for
young girls after this happened when you
when you were in prison or years later
well after i got through after i got
going with the treatment
like i said
treatment at arcadia was pretty
extensive i mean you had to do
writing reports
you had to play role models
about you being the victim or the other
person being the victim
and
the
it was set up to where you would be
aware
of places you shouldn't go when you got
released
people you shouldn't shouldn't associate
with
because of the problems you had
with the attraction
and it was it was very good a good
treatment program i've heard about it
but even aside from the treatment that
they provided
the the desire
for
these kind of interactions still exists
no
or existed before you became you're 83
now so your libido is probably not what
it was when you were younger no it isn't
but when you were younger in your 30s
40s 50s maybe
you still had the desire i well i was in
prison up till i was 40 something oh i
see so
i still thought about it while i was in
prison
when i got released to go to arcadia and
start going through treatment
they would have they had groups in
arcadia
because i was like 13 or 14 guys and
you'd have a
a
doctor
he would ask questions and then the
group had asked you questions
they would tell you about their offenses
how they felt about them and you telling
them about how you felt about your
opinions
and it was uh it was very beneficial
in that interaction
did it help you build compassion or
empathy or understanding of what your
victim went through
and i realized that empathy was very
important in your life
and
[Music]
it it
it was it was a good program
and when i got released from prison and
came home
i came here to live and of course they
had treatment here at that time right
here in this office
and we'd have about
25 30 people in the group
and don sweeney the
doctor
he threw over the treatment he
he would ask
each one questions and they'd have each
other ask each other questions
and we'd challenge each other
on the things we talked about
he would ask them about what they did
how their week went
you know and they would they would some
of them would answer the questions where
you could see that they hadn't changed
much
so we would challenge them
and they would challenge you
over your over your actions how your
thinking was going
tell me about your mindset
when you're
when you were doing this with the young
girls are you just
kind of blind to the repercussions that
might come afterwards and you're just
going after yourself i think i was
because i continued to do things
at that point
i didn't really
i thought about my wants
i didn't think about
how the victim would feel
how it would affect their life i didn't
think of those things
and uh but that that that you could call
it selfish or reckless behavior was that
something that
existed outside of your
sexual
uh no i i've always been a caring person
for people
my mother always bragged with her
friends lady friends and stuff
she says out of all my kids this is my
favorite
because he's just a caring person and
i've always been that type of person to
care to help other people and i say they
need to need needed help i would help
him so in those respects i was always
caring person note in that area how did
you
seduce the neighbor's girl
she came down to see my youngest
daughter
and i was home my wife was working and
there was no one ever with me
and i said well
my youngest daughter would be home
pretty soon i said you want to come in
and wait for her
and she came
in and i got talking to her and
and i i told her i says you want to play
a little game
she says what i i told her i says
i will take my penis out i didn't tell
her about penis but
and i said i want you to suck on it
so kids
kids i unders kids look up to grown-ups
they obey what grown-ups tell them
that was my
mode of operation that at that time
knowing that that's how they would react
well
i put my penis in her mouth
and she didn't like it so she pulled her
head back and opened her eyes
and she seen my hand with something in
it
and
they asked her
the prosecuting attorney's office to
represent to talk to her
they asked her
what did she see when she opened her
eyes and she says i've seen it
i've seen his uh privates
they said well how did you know that's
what it is private she's i've seen my
brother
and
they they weren't going to have her come
to court because of the
the shock and they the hurt
and the shame it's got to be traumatic
for a young girl right
and so she didn't come to court when i
got sins on the plane negotiation
my daughter
chose not to come
she could have come if she wanted she
chose not to
so
i was in court by myself with my lawyer
and they set it up where i'd be released
in
prison well the morning i was going to
be released from prison
the arcadia people showed up and they
said no you had to release him to us
we're taking him to treatment at arcadia
and
[Music]
the arcadia is a sex offender treatment
center here in florida yes it's an
arcadia board
so
they took me from prison to there
and i was there in delegate in 2011
and then i was released to come to my
probation
my probation run while i was there
so when i got released and came here
as a place to live
they had treatment set up here
so they they asked me if i would take
treatment here
and
i got releasing treatment here
and then i decided to move out of the
park
another guy that lived here
him and i got a place over there behind
the comfort end on 54th
and so we've been living there since
i've been out
does it weigh on your conscience or do
you lose sleep over
maybe the damage you might have done to
these
were there other girls or just the two
that
you were convicted of the two i was
convicted now there are no others that
you
may have had interactions with
yeah yeah i mean so do you does your
conscience
it bothered me for quite a while even
though i went through treatment
it bothered me and uh
my neighbors they know that i'm a sex
offender
and
they understand that
i was honest about it and told them
and therefore we get along fine
and there's no problem with my
neighborhood
because they all know that that i'm
living there and i'm a sex offender uh
sex offenders seem to be the most hated
group in in our society
that's true because people don't
understand
some people change and some people don't
some people go through treatment
and they do not use what they learn
they continue having that desire
so they get sneaky about it
and they go on with their life
until they get caught again which they
will eventually
you have to be dead serious about the
treatment if you go into treatment if
you don't try to change
it's just a waste of time for you
in the taxpayers money or and it's it's
there's a lot of guys to get out there's
not much publicity about the ones that
do well
and that's bad
because the ones that do well
there should be publicity on that
because that encourages the ones that
are going through treatment
or they're having these hours that do
wrong again
to not do
you must have understood that you were
doing something wrong with your daughter
it went on for years yes but you still
continued what
what overrides your judgment
well
i just sort of numbed myself to that
i didn't i didn't
i didn't dwell on it about what i was
doing being wrong
the way i look back at it now
and i realized
that i was totally wrong
in my actions
i had a good wife
my daughters are both loving
and
they were trying to cope with what was
going on
when my neighborhood found out about me
going to prison
my daughters got taunted in school
and the neighborhood
kids didn't want to play with them
so my wife had to sell her house
when she got when we got a divorce in 88
she decided to sell the house and they
she married
they moved out of
out of the area
where my kids would not have to put me
tonight at school by
by
what my father what her father had done
yeah it leaves the trail of destruct
destruction doesn't it yes it did
and
i
i wished all that hadn't happened now
but it has
and i can't go away because i wish it
didn't happen
all i could do was try to do the right
thing with my life and what's left in my
life
and like i say i haven't contacted them
because i wasn't supposed to talk to
them unless they contact me
about what would you say to your
daughter if you could
what message would you
what would you say to your daughter if
you could communicate with i would like
him to understand
how sorry
a father i was for the things that i had
done to my daughter
and that they were good daughters
loving daughters
and i was the one that was wrong
and i'm totally sorry
i wish it never had to happen
and i'm glad that they're married now
and have their own children
and that they're doing well now
that is a great comfort too to know that
and that is
i
i think i've seen my youngest daughter
when i was shopping one day
and she thought she recognized me she
was coming in
out of walgreens
i mean walmart not wold greens she was
coming out of walmart
and she stopped and looked over at me
and kept staring
but she never did try to talk to me but
i think she recognized me
but she didn't know what to do
and of course i was afraid to approach
her
behind him saying i wasn't
able to contact him
and
she seemed to be doing all right she had
a little girl
in india
in her cart
and she finally turned and went on in
the store
and but i believe that was her
and she i'm pretty sure the way she kept
staring over at me that she recognized
me
marshall what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned from all
of this
most important message
you know how to word that
i learned that
that all the things i created
i did well
working and being a good father in that
respect
but the things i did to my daughter
and the neighbor's daughter
i learned that that was a terrible
terrible thing that i had done
and that i never wanted that in my life
anymore
and all the people i've met since then
since i've been out
they know i had a sex offense but i
didn't want
to share the details that i'm talking
about here now
because like i say people don't unders
when they hear that you have a sex crime
of course in my case i did have minors
but that they automatically jump on a
sex crime too minors
not adults
having sex together
and so
i just left it as a sex crime and they
didn't ask any more questions and i
didn't give any more questions to it
that's why i was a little worried about
having this interview today
because it's going on the internet
and i thought to myself you know
my neighbors know i have a sex crime
but do they really need to know all the
details of it the goriness of it
that i'm ashamed of
but i can't change what happened
if they flat out asked me
about it
i would have to be honest and tell them
and hope that they would try to
understand that
it was my past life not my present
and that's what i would hope for
yeah you seem reformed
uh i think i am okay
like i say each day i try to do the
right thing with life
that's all we can do in life
is making the changes in our life that
we make
and
think about the things we're going to do
and think about the things over here
that you shouldn't do
because the treatment helps you
realize those things over there are what
got you in trouble and hurt other people
and so i'm consciously keeping my mind
on those thoughts
for not occurring
to bed anymore
but continue going forward
with what life i have left
i would really hope that my daughter
someday before i die
will be able to contact me
and tell me how they're doing
and like i said i have grandchildren
that i've never i've said
my old my daughter my oldest daughter
that i had sex with she sent a picture
through my youngest daughter to me in
prison of her children
small snapshots
said to give these to dad
so in a way she still feels that you
know
i'm her father
there's a nice gesture on her part yes
very nice
and my youngest daughter she she wrote
me letters while i was in prison she
says dad i'm i'm graduating high school
i want you to be proud of me
she says i'm going to be getting married
very soon
and she sent me pictures of her and her
husband
and their little girl
and
that's why i was in prison i haven't
received anything since then
but those were nice gestures on their
part with all that happened in their
lives
absolutely
all right marshall thank you so much for
sharing your story
i hope i was able to give it a good
impression because that's what i wanted
to do
i want this i want this to be help to
other people if it can be
and
that's about all i can do i guess
all i can say
i thank you for the opportunity
to be able to talk yeah thank you for
sharing your story
being so courageous to talk about it
thank you marcia thank you
you